قد يستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي في تجنيد
الارهابيين هيئه مراقبه الارهاب في
بريطانيا تحدثت عن الكيفيه برامج الدردشه
للتقنيه تستطيع اقناع البسطاء والمتعصبين
خاصه من الاطفال والمراهقين والارهاب قد
ينطلق من غرف النوم بحسب وصف صحيفه
[موسيقى]
المسؤول عن تشريعات الارهاب بريطانيا
جانوفا هول تحدث عن المخاطر وهي اكثر
وضوحا من اي وقت مضى هذه التكنولوجيا
بحاجه الى اعاده الضبط لتعظيم الاستفاده
وتقليل المخاطر ولان الحديث في بريطانيا
يتزايد خلال الايام الماضيه كان الذكاء
الاصطناعي موضوعا اساسيا في محادثه رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني مع الرئيس الامريكي
بايدن خلال زيارته الاولى لواشنطن اوضح
سوناك ان بايدن يدرك هذه المخاطر والتاكيد
جاء في تصريحات خاصه للعربيه نائب المبعوث
الامريكي الى التحالف الدولي
هذا موضوع يعني يحتاج
الدراسه ومراقبه ففعلا يعني نراقب هذا
وامر وهناك هناك حوار بين
الدول تحالف الدولي
والشركات
التواصل الاجتماعي
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات